after this whenever he was lecturing
with the reaction he would hold up his
hand and say I had a hand in that
reaction
so this time I've got potassium
dichromate
some sulfuric acid and then finally on
top of this mixture which is in dissolve
in water I'm going to add some diethyl
ether diethyl ether is an organic
compound which does not mix with water
so if I add it carefully it should float
on the surface so if you look now you
can see there's a colorless layer here
riether with the dichromate underneath
so now I put some hydrogen peroxide into
this small beaker and we lad a little
and see what happens so watch carefully
and with luck something will change
so
what you can see is that there's quite a
violent reaction and the ether layer has
gone bright blue and the reason it's
gone bright blue is because we have
formed a chromium compound with the
formula chromium oh five which and
usually for an inorganic compound will
dissolve in an organic solvent and so
the hydrogen peroxide has oxidized the
chromium it was chromium oh for two -
it's now chromium oh five a quite a
dangerous compound and it's important
with this blue compound it's very
intensely colored so there isn't very
much here but one must be very careful
not to isolate this material there is a
famous story of became a chemistry
professor in Cambridge whose student
made a whole test tube full of this
solid compound and the professor was
shaking the test tube when it went off
with an enormous bang and removed two of
his fingers and after this whenever he
was lecturing with the reaction he would
hold up his hand and say I had a hand in
that reaction and the older students got
very frightened slowly what is happening
is that the hydrogen peroxide is mixing
and reacting with it but in a long tube
like this you don't get very good mixing
if I was to stir it with a rod or
something like that I don't have one
here it would all react at once but this
is quite nice to do it like this because
then you see the before and after color
at the same time and you can see the
reaction is taking place here and the
oxygen o2 which is released by the
reaction is coming up and you're left
with some of the chromium in solution
here and it's a greenish color for
chromium - so kind of like the
actionpoint is like a wave that's moving
down but that's nothing to do with the
chemistry that's because the mixing is
so bad in this sort of vessel that's why
chemical engineers have to design proper
shape vessels so that reactions go in a
controlled manner you so in this case it
wasn't very controlled to begin with it
all splitted out at the top which looks
quite spectacular but is not very good
practice
we're trying again this time a little
bit better
I put warm water in here so the reaction
may be faster and I'll put in most of
the acid as well and then a bit of
permanganate and now that we've got
enough peroxide still left you can see
it's decolorizing straight away